[âm nhạc]
mình thì
một tí về cái bảo vệ đồ án thì như dự
kiến thì sẽ bảo vệ vào thứ bảy tuần này
nghĩa là hai ngày nữa đúng không ạ ngày
17 thì
tính ra thì đáng lẽ là định bảo vệ cho
tuần trước nhưng mà các bạn vẫn chưa
Chuẩn bị xong vẫn chưa Chuẩn bị xong tài
liệu các thứ code Bây giờ vẫn đang ngồi
code Tôi tin là một vài nhóm nó đang như
thế
và thực ra Tôi không chắc về cái vụ Thứ
Bảy tuần này lắm Không chắc ở đây ở việc
là một là sợ là các bạn cũng tâm lý các
thứ thứ hai là kiểu đấy Chính vì tâm lý
Nên là các bạn có thể chuẩn bị không kỹ
nó sẽ thứ Bảy nó ảnh hưởng đến cả các
bạn những cái ảnh hưởng đến cả mình có
ảnh hưởng mình phải mình sẽ kêu gọi Nếu
mà chuẩn là mình sẽ kêu gọi
khá nhiều người tham dự nên là mình đang
cân nhắc
xem là các nhóm nói chung hôm nay mà bảo
các nhóm bảo vệ thử lại một lượt mà mình
duyệt ổn thì thứ Bảy thì mình chúng ta
có thể chuyển nhưng mà tôi vẫn muốn là
ít nhất là 3 4 nhóm bảo vệ chứ hai nhóm
thì về các bạn ít quá mời người ta về
xong người ta thấy có mỗi hai nhóm bảo
vệ cùng nó là 4 người là số 4 người xong
rồi người ta hỏi là khóa học của em chỉ
có 4 người học thôi à Buồn cười đúng
không ạ Ít nhất là mình
và lẫn cả là hai nhóm sẽ chưa kéo dài
được một tiếng
giả sử là 3 nhóm thì mỗi nhóm 20 phút
thì còn được một tiếng này 4 nhóm đi
mình vẫn nghĩ lý tưởng rất là 4 nhóm
xong rồi mình bảo là buổi hôm đấy
hơn một tiếng để mình còn kiểu Lấy le
với họ là kiểu hôm nay chúng ta kiểu chỉ
bảo vệ tầm 1 tiếng thôi còn những con
Buổi sau thì
thì kiểu nghĩa là chia chia cho đợt ấy
đợt 1 đợt 2 đợt 1 đợt đầu sẽ là kiểu có
ba bốn nhóm này thôi xong rồi ba bốn
nhóm thì đều rất là ngon lành nên họ sẽ
nghĩ là ừ thế chả được đợt sau chắc toàn
nhóm ngon chẳng có nhóm mà nữa chẳng hạn
thế nghĩa là ít nhất là kiểu hô hôm ấy
phải mềm mấy ông hiểu ý tôi mà Tuy là
tôi không
Tôi không thu phí cái gì cả nhưng mà dậy
thì đương nhiên là mình vẫn muốn là kiểu
người khác nhìn vào mình dậy thì nó phải
ra một cái gì đó
Khi mà mình mời mấy người kia tham dự
thì chắc chắn là mình cũng kiểu gần như
là nó cũng là cái gì nhỉ
cái tiếng của mình ở hai cái gì uy tín
uy tín
Mình mời mấy người kia không phải mình
dùng từ mấy người nó hơi hơi không Không
thể hiện rõ anh nha Tôi định mời các
thầy ở bên FPT cadimi FA tham dự nha các
bạn HR nhé các bạn hát rồi tôi sẽ đăng ở
trên lycan nó quá nửa HR cho tới sinh
không ạ tôi toàn theo tôi chỉ à đương
nhiên là các bạn tức Thực ra trên hạ
trên lycan tôi lại khá dễ dãi ai Tôi
chấp nhận kết bạn nhưng mà còn nếu mà
tôi chủ động kết bạn thì toàn Chắc chắn
là các bạn đến được sinh
rồi mình cũng lấy le
này và
chung là mời là mời thôi chưa chắc là
mấy người đấy có tham dự nó cả một thầy
nữa Dạy cùng trường cũ của tôi vào
ngồi ban phản biện
gì nhỉ
nói chung là các thầy kia nếu mà muốn
thì vẫn phải ngồi với ba phản biện kể cả
sếp của tôi muốn ngồi vào ban huấn luyện
được ám rồi có thể mời cả các thầy ở
trong
nữa nếu có cái Mạnh Tuấn này chẳng hạn
hay nói chung là số lượng người tham dự
có thể Thậm chí còn nghĩa là Được mời
tham dự Thậm chí có thể còn đông hơn cả
số lượng bình thường mình hay livestream
kiểu như này kiểu bình thường Chắc là 20
30 đúng không Để tôi cũng phải 10 20 30
người
đấy là ít đấy tôi để link công khai chắc
nhiều người sẽ hiểu hứng tò mò có thể ấn
vào xem xem có cái gì đặc biệt không đấy
Kiểu như thế
Nói chung là
Ờ
biết đâu đấy nếu mà mà rất là ngon thì
tôi đang xử lên YouTube thì quảng cáo
kênh của tôi chẳng hạn sử Thế
mấy ông bảo vệ không phải bảo vệ trước
một vài người nữa bảo vệ trên nghìn
người
Giọng anh này hay thế này xong rồi Kiểu
mấy ông cũng sẽ được Lấy le nữa không
Mấy ông làm ổn Tôi tin là tao nhỏ hôm
trước demo rất là ổn rồi Đồ án
đồ ăn mấy ông thế là ngon lành rồi mới
chỉ học đấy chính là chúng ta học chưa
đầy 1 năm đúng không ạ
Các bạn có thể biết code trước rồi nhưng
mà về cơ bản thì đấy tham gia hai khóa
học xong chỉ học online thôi mà chất
lượng là rất là ổn rồi
cái vụ bảo vệ thế Để xem hôm nay chốt
lại xem thế nào hôm nay mà các nhóm
Hôm nay các nhóm kiểu mình chữa qua đã
vượt qua nữa thì tốt thì thứ bảy tôi sẽ
đăng một loạt bài Còn nếu mà các nhóm
Nói chung là sau buổi hôm nay các nhóm
chủ động nhắn cho anh
lại là kiểu muốn bảo vệ kiểu dạng mà
muốn bảo vệ theo kiểu là chị anh anh
chắc là vẫn sẽ mời một thầy nữa trong
ngủ ngồi phản biện thôi nếu nếu mà giả
sử không muốn bảo vệ trước đông người
còn nếu mà kiểu chẳng sợ cái gì cả thoải
mái Ai tham gia cũng được đấy thì thì
tôi sẽ kiểu đăng một loạt gọi là một
loạt kênh truyền thông để quảng cáo luôn
kiểu thế để mà hôm hôm
kiểu số lượng người xem gấp đôi không
phải gấp đôi nữa ba gấp bốn lần
đấy
bảo vệ Đại học mấy ông sẽ thế hiểu dạng
nó là đồ ăn tốt nghiệp mà đúng không ạ
thì nó thứ nhất là nó phải rất là ngon
Nó rất là chuyên nghiệp cho xịn thứ hai
thứ hai là kiểu ông bảo vệ xong thì ông
sẽ rất sướng ông ấy Ông gâu hạnh phúc
trước rất nhiều người hiểu rất nhiều
người sẽ nhìn mình và mạnh ngưỡng mộ
kiểu như thế
cái câu này đã tí mình sẽ đăng lên
YouTube
không thể tránh được mà không sao nhưng
mà Đúng là mình nên chuẩn bị các thứ
chuẩn bị cả tâm lý chuẩn bị cả mic các
thứ thứ Bởi vì bởi vì có thể mọi người
sẽ thông cảm cho cho mình thôi nhưng mà
tự mình sẽ cảm thấy nó bị kiểu nó Cậu bị
nhụt tâm trạng một tí kiểu dạng kiểu tự
nhiên lúc đấy có vài vấn đề gì đó thì
chính mình bản thân mình cũng sẽ run hơn
đấy
là một câu hôm trước tôi mới nghĩ ra và
bình luận trả lời xem là cậu động lực
của bạn là gì câu này câu rất là mở tôi
đôi khi rất thích hỏi những câu mở của
như này không đi tán gái không hỏi có mở
như này nhé người ta là lời khuyên như
thế đừng có hỏi câu là có không Nó bị
ngắn ngủi quất lủn và nhạt nhẽo lắm mấy
ông nên hỏi một câu rất là mở đấy nhưng
mà đừng có mở quá đến nỗi là kiểu dạng
là sở thích của em là gì đấy thì nó nó
bị dài dòng quá và thực ra nó bị chung
chung của ai cũng có cái sở thích thế
Thế bây giờ em phải chuẩn đôi khi là mấy
ông sẽ thử hỏi những cái câu bị ngược
lại bình thường một tí kiểu là em ghét
điều gì nhất em à Em ghét những cái gì
hoặc em sợ điều gì nhất Vâng xong rồi sẽ
có những cái câu chuyện sau đó Tại sao
lại như Tại sao lại ghét Tại sao lại
không thích các thứ Tại sao lại sợ thế
nó rất là hay nó sẽ hiểu hơn là con
người người ta hơn thay vì hỏi về sở
thích rất nhiều người cùng chung sở
thích nhưng mà không nói rõ được
nó không thể hiện được tính cách người
ta nhiều nó không nói được cái quá khứ
người ta nhiều
bây giờ tự nhiên ông bảo ông sợ à
ông sợ một cái gì đó mà ít người sợ cái
đấy Ở đấy Chẳng hạn vì quá khứ không ạ
từng kiểu có vấn đề gì gì đó giống như
là có người từng bảo sợ bị phản bội đấy
Tại sao lại thế bởi vì trong quá khứ đã
gặp chuyện gì gì đó thì chúng ta sẽ hiểu
hơn và khi chúng ta hiểu hơn kiểu như
thế Chúng ta tránh mắc những cái điều
đấy thì bạn đấy sẽ có ấn tượng hơn là
việc ông làm những cái thứ mà bạn ấy
thích bởi vì nhiều người làm thứ bạn
thích lắm rồi
tự nhiên tâm sự hay đi xa quá rồi cái
động lực của của mấy ông là gì để mà nói
động lực của tôi
thì về cơ bản lại tôi không Tôi là một
người tham lam Tôi không hài lòng với
hiện tại của bản thân Hồi trước rồi còn
chẳng có gì để mà
để mà hài lòng luôn cơ Hồi đấy không
đúng nghĩa là không có cái gì cả Không
tôi từng kể rồi này đó là hồi cấp 2 của
tôi là Hồi đấy tôi chẳng có bạn bè gì cả
đấy tôi là thằng mọt sách nghiện game
không bạn bè chỉ có kiểu Weibo đi đi
trốn học đi hết thôi
tôi có một và kiểu dạng cũng chẳng chơi
về chơi thỉnh thoảng chơi với anh em
thôi nhưng mà cũng chẳng có gì để chơi
cả nghĩa là ở nhà không được chơi không
có gì cả
bố mẹ thì
công việc các thứ bận rộn các thứ gần
như là mình toàn tự kỷ
bạn bè không có xong ngồi kiểu áp lực
gia đình rất nhiều các thứ thứ Hồi đấy
tôi kiểu
ngồi đấy tôi nói chung ở nhà thì không
phải nhà còn đến mấy giờ tôi cũng không
có nhà chứ Chả thế Hồi đấy là ở nhà ông
bà ngoại Còn bây giờ thì thuận đang thuê
nhưng đang thuê nhà may mà hồi May mà
lớn lên kiếm được tí tiền thì mới thoát
ra khỏi cái chỗ đấy dùng từ thoát bởi vì
chỗ đấy Nó là phố cổ tức là nó như một
cái ổ chuột ấy Nó không phải là to rộng
rãi không có cái sạch sẽ gì đây đó là
bẩn Nói chung là
ở đấy Đúng kiểu rất là bế tắc và ở đấy
tôi nghĩ việc à đương nhiên về sau mình
muốn kiểu đương nhiên là ai chẳng muốn
lấy kiểu về sau lấy vợ xinh đẹp giỏi các
thứ Đàm đang rồi đảm đang không giấu các
thứ n thứ thì thì
làm thế nào để mà người con gái đấy để ý
đến mình khi mà mình đang trông trong
trạng thái hiểu Nói thẳng luôn có một
cái Hồi đấy tôi tự tin vãi chưởng đó Nhà
tôi không có nhà vệ sinh Tôi phải dùng
nhà vệ sinh công cộng ở trong cái ngõ
bẩn đấy Cái cảm tưởng ở phía sau nếu mà
dẫn vợ về
không thể đi nổi cái vệ sinh đấy mình
còn rất là rất là ngại đi chứ đừng nói
là vợ mình anh kiểu như thế nên là đúng
kiểu Hồi đấy Kiểu muốn mọi thứ thoát ra
khỏi cái nơi đấy Chẳng hạn động lực của
tôi hồi đấy nó chỉ đơn giản thế thôi
thoát khỏi chỗ đấy
được khi mà mình không có gì để mất thì
và mình kiểu có hoài bão như thế thì
kiểu cái ý chí của mình chắc cũng tương
đối cao và đương nhiên là không phải
ngày một ngày hai kiểu ý chí cho dù thế
nào nữa không phải một ngày một ngày hai
vượt qua được tôi không nản tôi cứ tiếp
tục kiểu làm những thứ và và Cái quan
trọng là thực ra tôi khác với nhiều
nhiều người cùng kiểu thế tôi từng quen
khá nhiều người cùng kiểu từng xuất thân
kiểu không có một cái gì trong tay như
thế và khi mà họ kiểu kiếm được ấy Hoặc
là họ dùng đủ dùng từ đủ thủ đoạn để
kiếm được để mà thoát khỏi nơi đấy họ
làm đủ mọi thứ kiểu tài chính hay đủ mọi
thứ thậm chí là lừa mọi người vân vân
hay là kiểu
kinh doanh hay đủ kiểu để mà thoát khỏi
thì
họ kiểu khinh người nghèo là một thế là
việc là họ kiểu dạng là họ quan trọng
vật chất lắm tôi không như thế Tôi cảm
thấy tôi bị ngược tôi lại không hề như
thế khi mà tôi thoát ra khỏi nơi đấy
xong đương nhiên là bảo bây giờ mình
muốn quay lại hay không nhưng mà mình
nhắc mình trân trọng Hiện tại mình cũng
trân trọng quá khứ khiến cho mình như
bây giờ tôi không bao giờ ước là ngay từ
bé thôi đã trở nên giàu Nếu mà ngay từ
bé tôi giàu chắc chắn tôi không được như
giờ
và kiểu tôi không Tôi vẫn không đấy thì
mấy ông thấy là tôi cũng không kiểu làm
mọi thứ vì vì kinh doanh vì lợi nhuận vì
vì mục đích cá nhân không vì tiền đúng
không ạ Nó khác với nhiều người nhiều
người khi mà thoát nghèo rồi họ vẫn kiểu
muốn làm giàu làm giàu hơn nữa để tránh
việc à về sau có thể quay lại kiểu kiểu
quá khứ tôi tệ như thế mỗi người một ý
mà đương nhiên là bởi vì bây giờ tôi vẫn
chưa có gia đình vẫn kiểu dạng còn may
mắn là kiểu kiếm được để mà đủ tiêu sống
không bị vướng thì mấy Nếu là sự có vài
người bị vướng thì khoản gia đình nữa
không phải vì bản thân mình Nhưng vì gia
đình Vì bố mẹ chẳng hạn họ phải kiếm
chẳng hạn không nói nhưng mà ít ra may
thì tôi không đến nỗi như thế
thì mỗi người có một cái động lực riêng
như thế các bạn sọ rõ ràng được cái động
lực của mình có nhiều người thì khởi đầu
lại may mắn hơn nên thành ra là họ bị bị
ở trong cái ranh giới an toàn à Bị không
phải ranh giới mà kiểu
bị trong cái vùng an toàn nên thành ra
là họ không phấn đấu gì lắm họ kiểu dạng
mà họ không nghĩ phấn đấu cũng không để
làm gì mấy để không thay đổi gì nhiều ấy
nên thành ra là là họ phát triển chậm
hơn so với nhiều người họ không muốn họ
không muốn thoát ra khỏi vùng an toàn
phải dùng từ như thế
nên họ đánh lỡ rất nhiều thứ cuộc sống
của mấy ông là như thế nào Sau một năm
mấy ông có thay đổi thấy bản thân mình
thay đổi nhiều không đấy
mấy ông sau sau mỗi nửa năm hay các thứ
thay đổi nhiều không Ngoài việc là nợ
Học phí nhiều hơn
yêu đương các thứ làm những cái thứ mà
người xung quanh làm thì thôi mình cũng
làm cùng thực sự là cũng chưa chắc là
cũng chưa chắc là cậu mình thực sự là
mình muốn mình cần cái đấy
Chẳng qua là mọi người cùng làm thì thôi
Ừ mình thấy là mình ở chỗ nhiều chán quá
Thôi mình cũng làm nhưng mà làm ở đây
vẫn chỉ mang tính chất à Đi Theo đám
đông nghĩa là nó vẫn có cái gì đó an
toàn nó không có kiểu dạng là nó thể
hiện rõ được con người bản chất của ông
không thể hiện rõ được là ông đang thực
sự là định hình được ông là con người
như thế nào
nó là nào giống như hồi trước mà tôi
chia sẻ một cái video cho mấy ông xem là
bạn có phải là người nhà hay không ấy
tức là khi mà bạn gặp đám đông khi mọi
giới thiệu bản thân mình để nói những
cái câu mà kiểu để mà thể hiện mình khác
với tất cả những người kia thì bạn sẽ
nói gì bạn sẽ ngồi nói tên bạn sẽ ngồi
nói tuổi bạn sẽ ngồi nói câu Mình đã học
gì làm gì đúng chứ thường là cũng chỉ cơ
bản là như thế hôm đó mà có thêm quê
quán chẳng hạn nhưng mọi người còn nhớ
đến bạn không Bởi vì bạn không nổi bật
bởi vì bạn không còn chưa xác định được
bản thân mình có cái gì nổi bật hơn
người khác hay là kiểu mình là con người
như nào thực ra không Không có những cái
tính từ mô tả được bản thân mình nói
thẳng là bạn là người bình thường bình
thường thì nó Nó kiểu nghe nó nhẹ còn
nếu mà nặng nề hơn thì sẽ là bạn là
người tầm thường Tức là không có gì nổi
bật
ông cũng mới hai mấy tuổi chủ yếu ở đây
là như thế thì
tôi cũng phải ví dụ hôm qua tôi cũng gặp
lại một người em
đấy kiểu dạng
sinh năm 97 À nhầm sinh năm 98 cũng học
trường cũ của tôi hồi trước bks
em đấy em bé con trai em ấy rất là giỏi
rất là đáng xi năng cũng kiểu Lan là
giống tôi là kiểu việc gì có thể nhảy
vào làm em ấy nhảy nhiều mảng hơn tôi
rất nhiều Em bé hồi trước à học về bảo
mật sau đó thì bây giờ cũng học lập
trình các thứ nhưng mà đã trải qua rất
nhiều cái nghề rồi chứ không phải là bây
giờ mới học công nghệ thông tin
à mới đâm đầu vào công nghệ thông tin
hồi trước là
đâm đầu rồi và làm nhiều thứ lắm đây rất
là giỏi mà em ấy nói chuyện rất là cuốn
các thứ
luôn và đương nhiên là em đấy Kiểu cũng
cũng bảo là đã tiếp xúc với rất rất
nhiều người rồi
để mà kiểu được như bây giờ kiểu dạng là
kiểu đi Gặp đối tác xong rồi gặp gỡ Nói
chuyện mọi người và đương nhiên là Cái
quan trọng là em bị giống tôi một điểm
nữa đó là không ngại sự thay đổi và
không ngại gặp người mới không ngại thử
cái mới
đấy là con người mà tôi hôm qua tôi có
đánh giá đó là người làm được và chơi
được nghĩa là không ngại thử cái gì đó
mới miễn là cái đấy nó không để lại hậu
quả gì cả em đấy còn uống rượu bia thôi
không uống rượu bia nhưng mà chỉ mấy ông
hiểu tôi mà kiểu dạng mà bây giờ ví dụ
nhé bây giờ kế hoạch của ông hàng tuần
nó là gì đôi khi nó nhạt nhẽo chẳng biết
làm gì cả cuối tuần chẳng biết làm gì cả
cũng không biết gặp người mới không gặp
thêm ai Cái thứ có thể chỉ nằm nhà lướt
hoặc là gặp đi gặp lại những con người
cũ cũng không biết nói chuyện gì đi cà
phê gặp lại người cũ hết xừ chuyện để
nói rồi lại lôi cái điện thoại ra chẳng
hạn như thế đấy thì mấy ông nên phải
thay đổi thử cái gì đó mới thử đi ăn nhà
hàng mới đi đến nơi mới Vâng có nhiều
người thì tôi thấy là cũng có chịu khám
phá hơn đó là đi du lịch các thứ tôi còn
hơi bị lười khoản đấy nhưng mà người ta
đi du lịch người ta cũng khám phá thêm
các thứ thứ cũng cũng làm một cách một
cách thôi Thực ra tôi cũng không hẳn là
bảo là cách nào là cách chuẩn nhất nhưng
mà kiểu đấy đại khái như thế
À
đúng rồi Thậm chí là mấy ông ngồi ở nhà
mấy ông xem giống như là tôi thường hay
ngồi xem chương trình
truyền hình chẳng hạn hoặc ngồi xem phim
hay ngồi đọc truyện tranh vân cũng có
Nhưng mà quan trọng là mình nó sẽ hay
kiểu nó là lá giống kiểu có người mà đọc
nhiều sách có người đọc
kiểu ông rất nhập tâm vào đấy mà quan
trọng là cuốn sách đấy cuốn sách gì nữa
có nhiều quyển sách Nó kiểu nó nó chẳng
để lại được cái gì trong dậy dậy được
mình gì đó nhưng mà nó vẫn kiểu dạng là
sẽ ảnh hưởng đến mình Nếu mình nghĩ
nhiều về nó chứ không phải đọc kiểu dạng
là Ừ thì biết nội dung hết không rút ra
được một cái gì cả thì nó lại hơi bị
nhàm chán quá
hóa cả để suy nghĩ của cái người làm ra
hay các thứ thứ thì nó cũng hay mà
chỉ có thứ bảy là có người coi bảo vệ hả
Anh
chắc là thứ bảy sẽ sẽ
bảo vệ như thế nào nhưng mà Cùng lắm
cùng lắm kiểu gì tôi sẽ mở bạn có thêm
một người phản biện nha Còn sau đó thì
chắc là Tí mấy ông các nhóm sẽ inbox tôi
đi để mà để mà kiểu căn nhóm có đồng ý
thì được thứ bảy đông người không Rồi
tôi sẽ chốt xem như thế nào
Ok hôm nay có một nhóm cũng nhờ chữa
chữa tài liệu để tôi xem lại nhé
đi
rồi còn ngồi code cái gì nữa
Nhóm hôm nay nhóm nào muốn chữa mẹ không
nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
đi nhóm 16
mấy ông Xóa bớt đi cũng được cho đỡ
tìm kiếm này việc Lion
trả về URL có request
này thôi từng kiểu là điện thoại như này
đầu dự án kết thúc đấy
phải đi sang ta rồi này
cái này nó kiểu mô tả nó chung chung quá
thì nó nên là lọc lọc ra những sân theo
khu vực này theo thời gian
đang chấm Cụ thể như thế đúng không
trang đi chẳng hạn thế
cần phải server hay clayder ở đây Trừ
khi em làm majack
thế này xử lý bằng database hết à
Thì nó đâu phân biệt client với server
đâu nếu pp hết thì ở tôi sẽ là lấy toàn
bộ những cái
là có truyền lên những cái gì không sau
đó thì
cậu lọc theo những cái đấy ra những cái
sân trống
sau đó thì trả về danh sách rồi đồng
thời là
điền lại những cái mà người dùng đã kiểu
đã lọc thế thôi
chứ không không phân biệt client server
ở đây cũng như không cần phải ghi ghi
mấy cái này thì nó bị chung chung quá Em
thấy là nó cứ lặp đi lặp chẳng khác gì
cả hai bên nó sẽ không khác gì nhau mấy
này
được ông ấy xử lý toàn bộ bằng
pp hay là kiểu có rams gì ở đây không
Không có gì cả
này nó không nó không
cần phải ghi danh sách kiểu như này mình
có thể ghi như này thôi
sửa lại cái đoạn đấy nhé sơ Hợp thể này
Hôm trước thì tôi có nói là kiểu tôi
phân tích lại kiểu mình làm sơ đồ thể
nói chi tiết hơn đấy nhé
các bạn nên làm sổ để chi tiết thì hôm
ấy dễ trình bày hơn đấy chi tiết như nào
thì chắc là hôm trước tôi cũng có kiểu
hướng dẫn các bạn rồi là bây bạn này
thức ăn Chỉ có cái này bạc không nhiều
lắm Ok
phân công công việc
nhờ Có mỗi một bạn à
một bạn lên kiểu Nếu có một bạn thôi thì
không cần bỏ qua cái phần phân công công
việc nhé
Kết luận hơi ít kết luận thì có cả Vũ
hướng mở rộng càng tốt Ok
xem thử PowerPoint bạn này xem nào
nhỏ và to là gì
chả hôm đấy Nhưng mà thực ra là ghi tiêu
đề này không biết được là hôm đấy sẽ
trình bày như nào để xem bắt được lịch
đặt sân
biểu tượng cái này nhớ bên này biểu
tượng khác này lệch theo cái chỗ này nó
đang kiểu thẳng dóng thẳng hàng như này
nhưng bên này thẳng hàng nhé
các bạn để ý đoạn này một tí này sơ đồ
bạn này ít nên thành ra là bạn là
những bạn vẫn nên chỉnh Nó kiểu nó kích
thể cho nó giãn ra một tí cũng được
không ảnh hưởng lắm giãn ra cho nó to ra
một tí cân đối
hướng mở rộng vuốt chưa có hướng mở rộng
này
tránh việc ở trình bày
slide nó ngắn quá các bạn hoàn toàn có
thể thêm một vài tính năng gì đó mà các
bạn cảm thấy rất là hay các bạn sẽ trình
bày ở trong slide nữa càng tốt các bạn
có thể là kiểu
chụp lại ảnh nền cũng được cũng được
nghĩa là chụp ảnh lại giao diện cái đoạn
mà kiểu làm tính năng đấy cũng được để
mà nói qua là tính năng đấy nó như nào
giả sử để nổi bật được là cái phần mềm
các bạn có những tính năng nào tính năng
mà xịn nhất ngon nhất
có thể là có thể ví dụ ví dụ ở cái trang
này của bạn đấy thì có thể tìm cái tính
năng tìm kiếm này tính năng thống kê
chẳng hạn thế rồi quản lý gì gì đó quản
lý nếu mà dài hơn thì thôi Nhưng mà đại
khái như thế thì để cho cái Sunlight nó
không đi ngắn quá đoán một thì đương
nhiên là chẳng có cái gì để khoe cả này
thì còn còn thì thì mình có thể ngắn còn
đồ ăn 2 rất nhiều cái để khoe rất nhiều
bài toán nghiệp vụ thì các bạn có thể bổ
sung vào trong slide và slide hạn chế
kiểu nó dài hơn một tí Mình sẽ kiểu ngồi
khoe được các tính năng quan trọng của
cái phần mềm thì người khác sẽ để ý hơn
hơn là kiểu nó đều đều mấy ông hình dung
không Nếu mà đều đều thì người ta cũng
tưởng là cái đồ án của ông nó chả có gì
đặc biệt cả
tài liệu đây đúng không
mà đúng không
không nhé
đã không
tin hoặc là lấy thông tin về thôi không
cần phải ghi lại đúng cái trên này đúng
sai chuyện có bước 3 bước 3 là gì
bước 4 ở đây là gì
quay lại thông báo thất bại được rồi
Không thì mặc định sẽ nhảy xuống dưới
cho mọi người Cảm ơn bạn nhiều Tôi Đôi
khi tôi không phân biệt được mấy cái câu
này là mấy câu của Boss hay là người
thật nữa
Nhưng mà dù sao cũng cảm ơn bạn
Ok đầu vào không thì bỏ qua em ạ Anh
không cần ghi trong này Đâu nhưng mà
thôi cũng được đi vào kiểu Đã điên không
phải để trống đúng không
trang chủ admin
tính năng làm việc có tính năng nào khái
niệm tính năng trang chủ hả Chỉ có Ừ thì
đúng là menu mình sẽ có cái kiểu đấy Đây
không phải tính năng Nó là kiểu Nó là
kiểu đây giống như kiểu em đang hiển thị
ra đây là nó gọi là thống kê Đắk Lắk
thống kê thống kê tổng quan dùng từ như
thế làm gì khái niệm tính năng là tính
năng trang chủ đúng không
là 12 tháng
một loạt thống kê các thứ gồm hết chung
vào trong một tính năng Ok
các alendar
Xem lịch
mô tả mô tả dài dòng hơn nhé
người thật bạn shipper chẳng hạn Ok cảm
ơn bạn Mình cứ tưởng cậu đôi khi là có
một vài con boss vào đấy vào đây spam
xong rồi tầm một lúc nữa người spam hơn
cả linh 18+ nữa không biết đường nào
tả này nếu phải ghi rõ chi tiết ra đó là
kiểu
bản chất là toàn bộ cái tính
toàn bộ những cái cái dưới này này nó là
nó là để làm gì Giả sử để để mà kiểu để
mà đấy mô tả này chủ yếu là để cho vừa
cho lập trình viên đọc qua hiểu được
tính năng này nó là gì thứ hai là cho
người không phải lập trình viên cũng thể
hiểu được à tính năng này bản chất toàn
bộ những cái dòng dưới dài dòng này nó
để làm cái gì Ví dụ trong trường hợp này
nhé
Nó là xem
xem lịch cái gì Xem lịch gì lịch chưa
Cái gì đấy Bây giờ tôi phải ngồi đọc
từng dòng như ở đây tôi ngồi để tôi hiểu
được là cụ thể là xem cái lịch gì chẳng
hạn thế
có một số lỗi của lưu ý là hay
ok ok
được luôn Nếu mà ông ghi mỗi tính năng
là cái mô tả xem lịch xem quyển lịch à
lịch âm lịch
nhưng mà không có thêm những thông tin
khác đúng không đấy còn những cái ghi
chi tiết hơn trong này tôi không bán đến
nữa có vẻ chi tiết hơn Nhóm kia và nó
khác biệt vào nhóm kia Nhóm kia thì đều
ấy trên là lấy thông tin đã nhập này 2
cái thứ hai là load từ loa từ DB để lọc
này cho ba là trả về kết quả kết thì
nhìn nó thấy không Cốt được còn ở đây
thì
đây Có vẻ chi tiết hơn nhìn ở đây có vẻ
có vẻ cốt được
Tôi không biết bạn nhìn vào có được
không thì nó sẽ ổn hơn cái kia
như phần mô tả của ông ngắn gọn quá phần
mô tả này nó lên là văn xuôi nhá nó nên
là văn xuôi để ngồi nói qua tính năng
này nó là gì
Nó không phải là cũng ngắn gọn như cái
phần tên tính năng nó còn nó còn dài
dòng hơn phần mô tả Thế ông vứt xừ cái
phần mô tả đi cho nhanh
Sửa lại cái phần mô tả này cho tôi này
à đây đây đúng không
Cũng được thực ra nó chọn một trong hai
thôi nhưng mà thôi cũng được trong slide
của ông ấy Tôi không biết là ông có cả
hai hay không
Chỉ cần một cái để mà trình bày thôi nhé
tầm tầm tuổi đấy thì khi mà họ kiểu cảm
thấy là kiểu đấy họ muốn học môn phát
triển thêm thì vẫn được mà anh thoải mái
tuổi
cũng học lập trình cũng làm cái gì đó Em
không
giới hạn được bản thân mình mà quan
trọng là kiểu mình bắt đầu đương nhiên
có thể muộn hơn người khác nhưng mà mình
mình so bản thân mình phải quá khứ thì
chắc chắn là mình đang cảm thấy mình
đang tiến bộ lên Thế là được gọi
dạng mà cụp 3 cái này vào trong một
trang để mà kiểu bấm vào thì sẽ load nó
load mà
tách con ba slide cũng được
công nghệ áp dụng đồ án
không không đi kiểu như anh em nhé
Không có cái kiểu xóa luôn cả slide này
đi được em ạ
Cái này cái gì
chưa biết cái này là cái gì Công nghệ áp
dụng vào
tôi phải trình chiếu cái này tôi mới
hình dung
là gì
nói gì cả
như này em nên có hẳn một slide chống
ghi hẳn sơ đồ thực thể sau đó thì hình
ảnh này sau đó tiếp theo là sơ đồ cơ sở
dữ liệu hình ảnh này thì nó hợp lý hơn
theo kiểu như này ok chưa
nhân tôi lại thích kiểu tách ra như này
hơn là dùng cái chuyển động của
PowerPoint Bởi vì bởi vì đôi khi ông ông
bấm thế ông phải ngồi đợi kết hợp việc
là
kết hợp việc quá ông mà lỡ bấm nhanh quá
ông bị qua Sang trang khác đấy
nó lại Mất công chuyển động lại nó ngu
si thực tế là nó giống trang web của ông
thôi Nếu mà kết hợp với quá nhiều quá
nhiều gian Script ở trên một trang mà
cậu mở mua đồ rồi làm đầy đủ tính năng
mà ông không load lại trang ông Thanh
địa chỉ ông vẫn giữ nguyên đấy thì khi
ông muốn bác quay trở lại một cái gì đó
ông không bác được vì rõ ràng là
Thanh địa chỉ nó vốn vẫn thế đúng không
ạ nên là đấy nhược điểm đấy đôi khi ông
có thể nhảy hẳn sang trang mới để về sau
ông hoàn toàn bác ông chỉ cần bấm nút
bạc hay làm sự gì đó nó quay trở lại
trang trước
nhược điểm riêng
làm này hơi dài dòng về sau dễ sửa rồi
thấy cái này nó cũng hay Chẳng qua nếu
mà người khác mà phải vào nhìn như kiểu
mình trông nó sẽ kiểu nó có thể đấy thì
nó sẽ trông dài dòng nhưng mà còn khi mà
người xem slide hoặc là khi mà mình ứng
biến nếu có vấn đề gì đó mình ấn nút bạc
quay lại nó rất là dễ
nào nữa không nhỉ
làm ví dụ trực tiếp Hay mình Nên học lý
thuyết rồi mới thực hành cái này Thực ra
thì
nó nó là do cách cách mỗi người học tiếp
tiếp thu kiến thức như thế nào Ví dụ giả
sử như cá nhân tôi thì đúng là tôi thích
kiểu thực hành giống như bây giờ Và tôi
cũng đang dạy cho các bạn là theo kiểu
là thực hành và dần dần rồi hiểu mình sẽ
biết lý thuyết đoạn đầu một ít này cơ
bản một tí này sau đó mình thực hành rồi
về Xong mình sẽ vỡ ra rồi Nhiều cái có
nhiều người thì kiểu quen kiểu học là
chỉ học lý thuyết thôi cũng hiểu rồi
cũng hiểu na ná rồi nhưng họ lại không
biết thực hành
có người thì kiểu phải học Song Song Vân
đại học chính quy giờ thường là đúng là
vẫn sẽ dạy thực hành lý thuyết rất là
nhiều ngành rất ít không phải là bởi vì
tôi nói thẳng là không phải là bởi vì
đấy là cái cách tốt nhất mà bởi vì do
chính các thầy đấy cũng không chuyên
thực hành Nên là các thầy đấy cứ nghĩ
rằng là lý thuyết của mình là nhất và
chỉ dạy lý thuyết dạy những cái thứ mình
giỏi chứ chứ các thầy thực hành kém các
thầy cũng kiểu sợ bị học sinh hỏi những
cái câu liên quan thực hành chuyên môn
nên thành ra là các thầy không dạy dám
dậy được khánh dạy thực hành ít nên
thành ra là khi mà sinh viên thực hành
sinh chẳng biết gì cả và sinh viên khi
thực hành Sinh viên hỏi thầy thì nói
thẳng là rất nhiều thầy kiểu
trốn tránh nên là nó cũng khá là tệ
chung là phải
chuẩn một tí là thứ nhất là mình học đại
học thì đương nhiên là vẫn là chủ yếu
vẫn là tự học nhưng mà
để mà hỏi về những cái thực hành thì
đúng là phải tìm đúng người hỏi chứ hỏi
các thầy thì tôi thấy là ít hay trả lời
được lắm
còn về cách học như thế nào Thì đấy là
do cá nhân Mỗi người
ví dụ là kiểu tôi có quen nhiều ông kiểu
đúng không Màu xanh ông ngồi đọc được
sách thuật toán các thứ thứ ông ấy đọc
hiểu vãi chưởng ngay chẳng hạn thế tôi
không được như thế là tôi nghĩ là cả đa
số bây giờ thì vẫn kiểu dạng là khó hình
dung được cái đấy thì đúng là thiên
hướng bây giờ là học thực hành sau đó
thì mới hiểu hiểu dần hơn ít nhất là
trong cái ngành nghề này
chưa có phải là kiểu chỉ có ba bốn nhóm
nhạc
hay thứ bảy mình cứ thử bảo vệ đi nha
các ông thấy ổn
không Tôi tạm trú là thứ bảy tôi sẽ mời
các thầy đương nhiên là mời thôi chắc gì
sẽ chỉ có một vài người tham dự thôi
nhưng mà nhưng mà nói chung là mấy ông
cũng chuẩn bị tâm lý trước mọi thứ đúng
không ạ
những nhóm nào tôi sẽ Tí tôi sẽ cậu nhắn
tin những nhóm đấy để xem là những nhóm
đấy cảm thấy thế nào thứ bảy bảo vệ được
không như thế nào
tài liệu Ok
thay đổi nhóm này có vẻ hơi ít 700kp
làm sang Facebook
nối cơ
nhóm
này chỉ có phân tích 4 tính năng chính
là đăng nhập phân công các thứ
Nói chung là trông cũng ổn phân tích này
ổn rồi nhưng mà hơi ít hơi ngắn có 18
Trang thôi bổ sung thêm em ạ
nhóm này còn chữa Đúng không cần chữa
cái này đúng không
nên nó phải nối thông qua mấy thằng kia
như này
nếu em đi kiểu này nó sai nhá Anh sẽ thử
ví dụ nha
đúng không tiếp theo mình sẽ có là
đấy thì nó sẽ là một khóa học có nhiều
Simon đúng không ạ của ánh sáng Mình chỉ
thuộc một khóa học Mình sẽ là 1n
tương tự thế 1 1 subject
ok chưa Như thế này cái em sẽ hình dung
được ngay à nghĩa là kiểu dạng là cái
cái kiểu Simon nó là mối liên kết giữa 3
tháng chứ không phải kiểu
Đây không phải thực thể em này sai rồi
Được chưa
attendant student cũng không phải thức
thể attenden điểm danh mới ở tập thể nó
là mối quan hệ giữa thằng này với thằng
này và thêm cái status ở nó là thêm cả
Chibi satos nữa thì nó chưa Bill thì em
thèm đây này xem nối vào là được
một cái Chibi vào ok chưa sửa lại cái
thức thể này nhé Nói chung là thể nó
đúng thì mới ra được không ạ
chắc là buổi hôm nay tôi cũng chữa được
cơ sở nhóm rồi
và cũng cảm thấy tài liệu các bạn ổn ổn
dần rồi các bạn làm thêm slide cho nó ổn
nữa thôi là được
smile thì được ra tội không yêu có khắt
khe lắm đúng không ạ
bởi vì word mà Ổn rồi slide copy sang
thôi có thể đấy vừa rồi Tôi thấy rất là
hay chắc là các bạn đã học hỏi từ đó một
đó là các bạn để ít chữ đúng không ạ
slide các bạn không nhiều chữ thế có tốt
rồi Không phải kiểu slide ngồi giới
thiệu giới thiệu vấn đề mấy ông cópsule
ở trên mạng về chục dòng ngồi đọc và vỡ
mồm như thế bạn nhìn Style nó chỉ ý
chính thôi các bạn từ đấy mà nói đúng
không ạ giống như nhóm vừa nãy vấn đề to
vấn đề nhỏ
Ok
một nhóm là muốn chữa hay là gì nữa
không Không thì buổi mai chúng ta kết
thúc ở đây nha
ông tán gái đâu phải con vợ nghĩ gì mà
sợ
con gái rồi nó cũng kiểu sợ văn vở lắm
điển hình bây giờ thế nên tôi không đi
tán gái được bây giờ mấy ông cứ kiểu trụ
chân thành rồi chân thành và thật lòng
là được
văn vở các bạn nên sợ lắm nhưng mà các
bạn Đấy nó hơi buồn cười như
thứ 7
thứ 7 nếu bảo vệ thành công thì
quá ngon rồi
chuẩn bị các thử thử đi chấp nhận hộ bây
giờ cũng thức đêm mày làm nốt tất cả các
thử đi để thứ bảy duyệt nhé Ok chào các
bạn